متحور جديد من فيروس كورونا يجدد المخاوف
التي لم تهدا بعد لدى الجهات الصحيه
والعالم باسره فمنظمه الصحه العالميه كشفت
عن متحور ينتمي لسلاله اوميكرو لكنه يمتلك
ميزه النمو بشكل اكبر المتحول المعروف
باكس بي بي وان فايف يعاد اكثر المتغيرات
القدره على الانتشار بين كل السلالات التي
اكتشفت حتى اللحظه اكس بي بي 1 5 اعراضه
مشابهه لاعراض سلالات او ميكروسابقه وان
كان من المبكر تاكيد ذلك وفق منظمه الصحه
لكن هل المتحول الجديد اكثر عدوى او خطوره
من المتحورات السابقه تطور مشاهدينا اكس
بي وان فايف من سلالات اكس بي بي ولكن
اخذت بالانتشار في بريطانيا خلال سبتمبر
الماضي لكنها لم تصنف كم متحور مثير للقلق
من قبل السلطات المحليه الصحيه المتحول
الجديد سبع طفرارات
ما يزيد صعوبه الا المناعيه في التعرف على
المتغير الفرعي والزياد احتماليه التفادي
الاجسام المضاده احدى الطفرات تجعله ينتشر
بسهوله فيما يعتقد ان طفره اخرى تحسن من
قدره المتحور على الارتباط بالخلايا غير
ان علماء طمان الى عدم وجود ادله تثبت ان
المتحول الجديد اكثر خطوره او ضررا من
متغيرات او ميكروس السابقه